time to check the traps
when abdul gophor empties his nets his
bucket is filled with wriggling shrimp
[Applause]
my daily yield has increased a lot
usually i get a daily yield of a half to
one kilo in normal seasons
but thank god even in this difficult
season it's more than three kilos so i
have a good daily yield
that wasn't always the case
for centuries fish farmers like gophor
in demac regency in the indonesian
province of central java have earned
their living fish farming
his parents also earned a living with
fishing but up to a gofor's generation
have seen conditions deteriorate fast
a lot of fish farmers use chemicals
such as
pesticides
when using chemicals the first results
are very encouraging
moreover many of the mangroves were
removed to make way for the shrimp and
fish ponds
up to 40 percent of indonesia's mangrove
forests have disappeared
the fishers here are learning how
important these trees are for
aquaculture
under the guidance of scientist sri
rajiki and her team
some of people think that mangrove is
only used for
firewood
or
for
building materials
but
after mangrove corn
they realized that after the beach the
coast is
eroded and the denmark area is very
suffer from that
together with the fishers sri rajiki has
been reshaping the ponds
the fish farmers have agreed to
construct new levees and systems of
locks
by regulating the flow of water sediment
collects in certain places mangroves
grow there naturally the aim is to
create a vibrant green band of mangrove
forests to act as a protective barrier
between the land and the fish ponds
this mangrove fruit is very important
for the ecosystem especially for the
coastal ecosystem these roots can
trap the sediment so it uh avoid
erosion coastal erosion as well as the
river embankment
these fruits also have another function
because it could
it can absorb the pollutant included
including heavy metals
as a result the water quality has
improved
the natural environment is less intact a
bit further west in the kendall regency
the remaining mangroves struggle to
withstand the increasingly strong tides
caused by the warming of the seas
fish farmer sutrisno is repairing his
pond
it keeps getting destroyed by the flood
tides wiping out his income too
as
in some areas of the region a lot of
planting is going on thanks to the
commitment of wasito a former fisher
he's been planting mangroves for over a
decade now
at first the residents ridiculed him
until some coastal strips began to
slowly recover from the flooding now
many people are joining him he's become
a local hero and he can use the help
because time is running out
here many people's ponds have
disappeared
the embankments are also no longer there
they've been covered by seawater
this situation needs to get attention
from the government and the local
residents
especially to maintain this last
embankment so it doesn't collapse
if this last embankment collapses the
settlements will be directly affected by
erosion
the indonesian government supports some
mangrove reforesting projects but not
juacitos
he has a nursery of his own and pays for
its upkeep
back in demac sri rajiki and the fishers
receive funding from universities and
private investors
training also gets financial backing
abdulgofor has learned to create organic
fertilizer with the help of mangrove
leaves
he composes them together with goat dung
and seagrass and ferments the mixture
he uses the runoff to keep the bottom of
the pond intact and fertile
[Music]
the money can be used for my children's
school needs
a growing number of indonesian shrimp
and fish farmers like abdul gofor are
doing their bit to protect the mangroves
rather than deplete them
the farmers are working together with
nature
you